hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
a little bit past the midpoint of book
three of his poem on the nature of
things lucretius is going to make an
entire set of arguments
aimed at showing that the mind the
anonymous and the spirit the vital
spirit the anima both closely connected
to each other in us human beings
are in fact mortal as is the body that
they are
interconnected with and this is not just
going to hold for us human beings this
will hold for every animated thing like
animals as well and it's not just that
they're mortal that they will have an
end to them
it's also
that they have a
beginning and so he this latin phrase uh
nativos at mortalis essa the
the being there animos animos que so the
plural of minds and bodies minds and
bodies are
born
they are things that arise they come
into existence and there are things that
die things whose existence ends so they
exist or they have being for a certain
amount of time but both sides are
actually
you could say bookended by non-existence
and he begins by saying first
note that that both of these things my
you know the the mind and the
spirit are to embr be embraced under one
name when i proceed to demonstrate that
spirit is mortal you must understand
this applies equally to mine why because
the two are conjoined to constitute a
single substance that is that is our
psyche you could say whatever however
you want to call it right
and he begins by saying first of all as
i've shown
spirit
mind is flimsy stuff right it's easily
blown around you could say it's composed
of very very fine tiny particles so you
know what is the upshot of this it's not
going to exist
on its own because if it's outside of
the body the body is its vessel and it's
just going to be easily blown away
he gives the example of you know water
flows out in all directions from broken
vessels and the fluid departs and mist
and smoke vanish into thin air be
assured the spirit is similarly
dispelled and vanishes far more speedily
because its particles are smaller and is
sooner dissolved into its component
atoms once it's been let loose from the
human frame which is it's it's death
it's ending right it doesn't remain in
existence
so that's an interesting argument that
he's making there
and then
he'll make a much
more extended argument or discussion
talking about how the body
and the mind both grow up together and
they grow old together and he's going to
give a lot of
interesting examples here he says that
with the weak and delicate frame of
wavering childhood goes a like infirmity
of
judgment the mind is not really
operating that well in an infantile or
childish body the robust vigor of
ripening ears is accompanied by steadier
resolve mature strength of mind later
when the body is palsied by the potent
forces of age and the limbs have
collapsed with blunted vigor the
understanding limps the tongue rambles
the mind totters everything weakens and
gives way at the same time so the body
gets weaker the mind gets weaker the
body gets stronger the mind gets
stronger and you know
it can go the other way as well and he's
going to give a whole bunch of examples
of how the mind
is affected by the body and vice versa
both for good and for bad so he says as
the body suffers the horrors of disease
and the pains of pain
we see the mind
stabbed with anguish grief and fear
what is more natural that it should have
a share in
death in the body's illness the mind
wanders right and then he says um here's
another example
when you drink wine the pervasive power
of wine as he says when it's entered
into a person and its glow is dispersed
through their veins the limbs are
overcome with heaviness the legs stagger
and stumble
but it's not just that his speech is
slurred right his mind besotted his eyes
swim there's a crescendo of shouts
hiccups quarreling and all the other
symptoms follow and do order and then he
says why is this the case
well because the wanton wildness of the
wine has the power to dislodge as he
says the vital spirit
within the body
so you know a more potent attack would
make an end of both of them the body and
the
spirit and the mind
he says
this happens sometimes when somebody has
epilepsy he falls as though struck by
lightning and foams at the mouth right
the raving occurs why
because
mind and spirit are
dislodged and as i've explained split up
and scattered this way and that by the
same
poison right and then he says you know
think about medicine medicine
positively
can improve the body and thereby improve
the mind so we can and this can go both
ways as well
we can engage in you know you could say
cognitive or emotional
medicine and thereby benefit the body as
well because they are so connected
with each other
so
he goes on and he says that we often see
a man pass away little by little and
lose all sensation of life limb by limb
first the toes and toenails then the
feet and legs die after that the imprint
of icy death steals by slow degrees
through the other members
since the vital spirit is dispersed and
does not come out all at once in an
entirety it must be regarded as
mortal so the fact that the mind and the
body
are so closely connected as to affect
each other you might say share the same
fate
means that the mind
is going to be
mortal
he goes on and he says that
there really isn't any
single location of the
mind or the spirit in the body
all right so he says
uh here we go if it you know if it were
so that the mind could shrink itself
through the body and draw its parts
together and withdraw sensibility from
every limb
then wherever it's concentrated ought to
show
a exceptional degree of sensibility but
we don't see this
instead what we see is a lack a loss of
sensibility and it's clear that the mind
is itself
dying right and he goes on and he says
the mind again is one part of a person
and stays fixed at a particular spot no
less than the ears and eyes and other
senses
um but you know
you know it's it's uh
deriving it's it's
vigor in its vitality from the
conjunction with the body without body
the mind alone cannot perform these
vital
motions and you know what we see is that
as parts of the body are dying away
so is the mind in many respects as well
he'll talk a little bit later
about this and note that
there you know when people are losing
limbs or stuff like that he's got some
pretty graphic things about warfare and
chariots and stuff like that or snakes
being cut into bits so long as there's
still some of the vital spirit within
the parts they're moving around but then
that goes away
very quickly which shows that it's
diffused throughout the body right it's
not concentrated just in
one little node or spot or something
like that
now
another interesting argument that he
gives is more of a if this was the case
than we would expect this to happen
and he talks about the depiction of the
soul apart from the body for example in
greek myths when people go down to the
afterlife and they can hear things and
see things and even smell things you
know the dead and homer come and taste
the blood that odysseus is laid into a
trough for them
and
um lucretia is going to say well that
doesn't actually make any sense right
you don't have
um bodies
going around or my mind's going around
spirits going around and sensing things
without the
the sense organs
of the body he says our hand or eye or
nostrils in isolation from us can't
experience experience sensation or even
exist in a very short time they rot away
so
mind cannot exist apart from the body
and from the human being himself or
herself who is as it were a vessel
for it so you're not you're just not
going to have what is being depicted you
don't have senses apart from the body
he also considers some ideas that people
have you know among the philosophers of
the platonist would be particularly
a target for this the idea being that
the spirit enters into
the body
at birth and notice that it doesn't say
at conception or anything like that the
idea back then was generally at birth
and he says that um
you're not going to
you're not going to get
that um
happening and and why not well for a
couple different
reasons
he says if the spirit is by nature
immortal and is slipped into the body at
birth then
why don't we have any memory
of an earlier existence no traces
left by antecedent events so this is
directly targeting
the platonists the pythagoreans and some
other
groups that that thought that the soul
engages in a sort of
reincarnation or trans migration moving
from body to body to body
and
i mean this is actually a good
objection
the platonius do say well you have to be
reminded of the things because you
forgot it well why'd you forget it
that isn't adequately answered just
saying well you go into a body and the
body makes you forget
it's not really a answer to the the
question is it
he also said something kind of
interesting so if we assume
that
reincarnation would happen not just for
human beings but for animals as is
typically the case when people believe
in that then we'd have a bit of a
problem because animals
more than human beings seem to have
rather fixed natures
that are at least from the epicurean
perspective that lucretius is developing
here dependent on the
constituent parts of their bodies
and so
if we could have souls or minds or
whatever we want to call it spirits
entering into a wide range of animal
bodies then the animals wouldn't
actually have
their determinate
ways of behaving you know he talks about
the
hound would turn tail before the onset
of the antlered stag instead of actually
going and attacking the stag which is
what they do because they have you know
plenty of fire in them right uh the hawk
would flee trembling through the gusty
air at the coming of the
dove and then he says something else
really interesting
human beings would be witless and
brute animals would be
rational and that isn't the case at
least as far as lucretius is concerned
so
we don't have souls entering or spirits
or minds whatever we're going to call
them entering into bodies uh you know
that having existed before with their
own characteristics we don't have them
entering into bodies at birth
we have them instead developing with the
bodies from
their birth
onward
and he actually has another kind of
funny thing that he says here as well
it's surely ludicrous to suppose spirits
are standing by at the mating and birth
of animals a number a numberless number
of immortals on the lookout for mortal
frames jostling and squabbling to get in
first and establish themselves most
firmly or is there perhaps an
established compact that first comes
shall be first served without any trial
of strength between spirit and spirit
you say
this can't be the case right that's not
how things actually
work and then he says another thing that
i think is a different argument
it doesn't make sense
to couple things that are
totally unlike each other
with each other in the way that the mind
and the body
appear to be interconnected
if the mind is actually eternal or
deathless and the body is
you know broken up into its constituent
parts and it dies and stuff like that
then there really can't be an
interconnection of these two
radically
and distinct kinds of
whatever we want to call them substances
entities
instead what we experience is that we
are really this interconnection
of mind and spirit on the one hand and
body
on the other hand so you know that is uh
an interesting argument
and then the final one that he makes is
that
there are everlasting things
spirit and mind just isn't one of them
he says there can be only three kinds of
everlasting objects the first
owing to the absolute solidity of their
substance can repel blows and let
nothing penetrate them so as to unknit
their close texture from within what is
that atoms atom literally means can't be
cut can't be split now of course we know
that atoms can be so we might talk about
subatomic particles or something like
that right
so
spirit isn't that i mean it's composed
of a bunch of atoms because everything's
composed of atoms but it's not an
atom
and then he says the second kind can
last forever because it's immune from
blows
such is empty space which remains
untouched and unaffected by the impact
soul or mind or spirit is not empty
space it's atoms instead very fine atoms
so that's not the case and then he says
last is that which has no available
space surround no available place
surrounding it into which its matter can
disperse and disintegrate
it's for this reason the sum totality of
the universe is everlasting and having
no space outside it into which the
matter can escape and no matter that can
enter and disintegrate it by the force
of the impact so the totality of the
universe
well that's not what a spirit or mind is
her spirit or mind is a tiny little
thing inside the universe so
it doesn't fall into any of these three
categories and then he says well some
people might say
the spirit is immortal because it's
shielded by life-preserving powers it's
unassailed by forces hostile to its
survival or because such forces if they
threaten are repelled before we're
conscious of the threat he says
that doesn't make any sense common sense
actually tells us that this isn't the
case
because the spirit participates in the
ailments of the body we know that the
spirit is affected by things
and there's no reason to think
that it's immortal because it has
life-preserving powers that's
essentially just
begging the question you know why
why does it survive past death well
because it's immortal that's just a
circular argument and so uh lucretius is
saying it's a bad argument right there
so what this means is that the
mind or spirit
has a beginning it has an end it exists
during the time that it's actually there
but it will eventually break down and
its breakdown will more or less coincide
with the breakdown and death
of the body
you